I'm Zachary Feinstein I'm professor at
Washington University in st. Louis in
the department of electrical and systems
engineering I am Peter coy economics
editor of Bloomberg Businessweek I've
watched all the Star Wars movies dozens
of times doing them in a single day I
did see the first Star Trek movie and
I've seen little bits of some of the
others start Star Wars
[Music]
we are here talking about your paper
called it's a trap Emperor Palpatine is
poison pill there is a great disturbance
in the force my theory that I posit in
this paper is that Emperor Palpatine
planned it that if he were defeated
after the Battle of Endor in Episode six
there would be economic repercussions on
such a scale that the rebels would never
be able to take power in the Episode
four they build the first Death Star and
that is where Luke Skywalker blows up
the Death Star Episode six there's the
second Death Star and that one again
gets blown up this time by Lando
Calrissian
so the sheer scale of the debt for
building two Death Star's in such a
short period on top of the fact that
there is no true central bank within the
Star Wars universe and the repercussions
of these joint events would truly be a
staggering loss to the Galactic economy
now will you say all this where are you
getting this from it's not in the movies
is it no so it's coming from these books
from the movies from the TV shows and
you can choose whether you want to find
just what is considered Canon and what
is kind of considered legend at this
point I chose to accept anything that
was in Canon as much as possible and
anything that's not Canon I tried to
stay away from if I could at all avoid
it now let's just walk through the paper
a little bit perfect I started out
coming up with the price of the Death
Star so the first Death Star was one
hundred and forty kilometers in diameter
and this gave a cost of a hundred and
ninety three quintillion dollars for the
first Death Star the second Death Star
was nine hundred kilometers in diameter
so I came up with a cost of four hundred
and nineteen quintillion dollars for the
second Death Star how did you get from
there to mass financial chaos so the
problem is that the rebels killed
Emperor Palpatine and presumably do not
have a financial strategy for after they
take power
which would cause the banks to have to
write off 515 point 5 quintillion
assuming that some of the dead on the
first Death Star was already paid off
your argument is essentially that the
Rebel Alliance couldn't possibly get its
hands on the levers of power and run the
bureaucracy of the galaxy successfully
not immediately so my contention is
Emperor Palpatine had this as a trap
even if they do attack they can't kill
me they have to make an orderly line of
succession so I am still going to be
safe so it's sort of mutually assured
destruction exactly if the rebels head
said you know what we're going to honor
these debts there still would have been
a financial crisis due to the lack of
Deposit Insurance due to the lack of a
lender of last resort when the two Death
Star's were destroyed nothing of
productive use disappeared from the
galaxy so you could argue that as soon
as those Death Star's were destroyed the
debt paying potential of the galaxy
increased the debt paying potential of
the galaxy would increase if there is a
government that could collect those
debts to collect those taxes this is
clearly a product of an obsessed person
after having gone so deep into the
economics and finance can you really
just watch these movies like a regular
fan anymore I don't think I ever watch
these movies like a regular fan whenever
I watched TV shows or movies and I see
these type of questions popping up I
can't ignore it it's this is my life
you